bisher galten quantencomputer als extrem
ungenau für bestimmte berechnungen
können sie einfach nicht verwenden
werden weil ihre fehlerquote zum teil
fast 70 prozent liegt jetzt hat aber ein
forschungsteam der eidgenössischen
technischen hochschule eth zürich ein
verfahren entwickelt um diese
fehleranfälligkeit dramatisch zu
reduzieren wird jetzt eine neue ära des
kranken computings anbrechen klicks und
science fiction
hier gibt's täglich faszinierende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst er nichts herzlich
willkommen beim wettkampf der
quantencomputer 2017 war die fehlerquote
riesig der vorläufer des kommerziellen
ibm quantenrechner skew system trat
gegen einen quantencomputer der
university of maryland an der ibm
rechner war teilweise bis zu 1000 mal
schneller als sein konkurrent dieser hat
jedoch eine höhere zuverlässigkeit er
kam auf einen wert von 77 bis 90 während
der ibm rechner nur auf 35 bis 74
prozent kam
also deutlich mehr fehler machte das ist
immer noch das hauptproblem von
quantencomputern sie sind zwar
unglaublich schnell aber machen eben
fehler aber sie sind die computer die in
zukunft wahnsinnig komplexe modelle
durchrechnen können zum beispiel den
berg sind mit allen möglichen folgen für
wirtschaft und gesellschaft normale
computer scheitern heute noch an solchen
aufgaben brannten computer hat überhaupt
die möglichkeit bei rechenaufgaben mit
so vielen unbekannten eine menge
möglicher szenarien zu bestimmen ibm
rechnet mit fortschritten bei vielen
komplexen problemen
medikamentenforschung berechnungen in
der logistik finanzwirtschaft künstliche
intelligenz datensicherheit alles felder
wo wir mit der heutigen computer
technologie an grenzen stoßen aber wie
könnten die fehler von quantencomputern
eingeschränkt werden
ein forschungsteam um den physiker
johnson hat dafür ein revolutionäres
verfahren entwickelt dafür versetzen sie
die qubits eines quantencomputers in
ganz bestimmte schwingungen ein cupid
das ist das bild in einem
quantencomputer also wie die null und
eins in unseren herkömmlichen computern
im prinzip also das gleiche nur dass ein
kilobyte also acht verbundene cubes
nicht nur einen wert sondern alle werte
gleichzeitig end
kann also quasi schon mal dadurch 256
mal so schnell wie ein normaler computer
ist allerdings gibt es beim auslesen der
informationen immer wieder fehler weil
quantenzustände beschrieben durch die
heisenbergsche unschärferelation
zustände mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit
annehmen und diese zustände können durch
äußere einflüsse verändert werden
teilchen sind ja nicht nur teilchen
sondern auch wellen wie wir es beim
licht ja ganz deutlich erleben und den
schweizer forschern und forscherinnen
ist jetzt gelungen diese wellenfunktion
der teilchen so zu beeinflussen dass sie
nicht mehr wie weiche wellen aussehen
sondern wie zinken eines kampfs jetzt
sind die teilchen plötzlich gar nicht
mehr so unscharf sondern die
messunsicherheiten finden jetzt nur noch
an den ganz schmalen sinken dieses kampf
statt also die störungen sind jetzt viel
leichter zu sehen christa flühmann aus
dem forschungsteam unsere realisierung
dieser periodischen oder krampfartigen
schwingungen zustände des ions stellt
einen wichtigen schritt in richtung
einer solchen eventuellen fehler
bestimmungen dar
jetzt will das forschungsteam verfahren
entwickeln um die störung aufzuspüren
und dann herauszurechnen
bei einem nächsten wettkampf zwischen
quantencomputern könnte also die
fehlerquote schon bald stark sinken
quantencomputer darauf unbedingt klicken
ein mega video mit der erklärung des
quantencomputers also draufklicken
anschauen bei doktor watson übrigens und
den dann auch abonieren bis dann bleibt
dran